ey Leute was geht ab herzlich willkommen
zu einem Video ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht es allen gut wir haben gerade 11:30
Uhr im Bukarest sind eben aufgestanden
für die die es interessiert heute ist
Freitag und wir wollen heute nach
Istanbul mit dem Zug fahren ich habe
keine Ahnung ob wir es heute schaffen
werden mit der 18 es wird wirklich
glaube ich die filmlichste Reise des auf
jeden Fall die dieses Trips weil ich
habe halt noch kein wir haben noch gar
keine Tickets und es gibt halt keine
Direktverbindung mehr ich ja Leute was
geht ich sitze gerade im Schnitt vom
letzten Part der Zugreise und ich wollte
mal zwei Sachen sagen erstmal vielen
Dank für den Supporter ganz neue kommt
ja sehr gut an wird in Zukunft auf jeden
Fall auch mehr dazu geben ich habe aber
gesehen es haben nicht mal 30 % von
allen Leuten die Zug Videos schauen den
Kanal abonniert deswegen seid doch so
lieb wenn ihr euch dafür interessiert
und das cool findet lasst mir ein Abo da
freue ich mich sehr darüber und jetzt
machen wir weiter na ja wir werden sehen
und ich würde sagen wir checken jetzt
erstmal aus gestern waren wir noch
unterwegs haben zwei lustige Jungs
kennengelernt
[Musik]
ich weiß noch nicht wie ich damit um
gehen
wir wurden auch zehnmal gescammt gestern
wieder das ist so krass ne egal von wem
jeder erkennt in dir ein Touristen und
will dich scammen das ist hier so das
war ein Ungarn so Taxifahrer hat uns
auch gescammt erzähle ich euch gleich
noch mal let's go
Germany ja genau we will go to
easternbul bei train do you know this is
connection connection
ähm with the one like a night Trainings
cancelt so das no Training we have to go
to Burger in Bulgaria
from London too Istanbul so I started in
London und Monday here on Friday so wir
fahren jetzt auf jeden Fall zum Bahnhof
und ähm dann soll ich jetzt schon eine
Story erzählen wie wir gescammt und die
Taxifahrer sowie die erste also nicht
kostet Taxi fahren oder wir hätten für
den Weg so drei Euro umgerechnet bezahlt
am Ende waren es 15 und der hat seinen
Taxi Meter halt nicht angemacht und es
war unsere erste Taxifahrt hier deswegen
wussten wir nicht dass es halt wirklich
eigentlich so günstig ist
auch noch so weggedreht dass wir das gar
nicht sehen konnten ja keine Ahnung ach
und du wolltest das doch dann zu uns
drehen weil da waren die anderen beiden
Jungs auch dabei und dann hat er es halt
wieder zurück gedreht ne
dann waren wir in der Bar oder das war
so eine Club war ähnlich so ne ich
erzähle das jetzt einfach auf uns ein
bisschen unangenehm ist und der stand da
so und dann kam so zwei Mädels zu uns ne
und ähm die haben uns halt angelabert
und wollten mit uns zu reden wo wir
herkommen und so und ich dachte ja
sympathisch waren die ne und dann
wollten wir was trinken gehen mit denen
und ja ich habe dann gesagt ja gut und
ich wollte halt auch so bezahlen weil
keine Ahnung mache ich eigentlich dann
also die hatten ja auch nicht bezahlt
ist uns ja auch dann später aufgefallen
auf jeden Fall hat mir der Kellner dann
direkt so ein EC-Gerät hingehalten da
stand dann 220 Leute drauf oder lay dass
wir hier die Währung und ich habe halt
direkt mit Kreditkarte bezahlt so gar
nicht hinterfragt ich dachte mir ja wird
so 10 € sein oder so oder 20 vielleicht
nicht für die Shorts am Ende 50
und dann dachte ich mir so ey das kann
doch nicht sein Mann ich habe ich dachte
die wären einfach so nett gewesen weißt
du die wollte uns einfach scammen und
die anderen Stories sparen wir uns
einfach mal weil dass wir nur
unangenehmer aber es war jetzt nichts
schlimmes oder so ab zum Bahnhof also
der Verkehr knallt hier auf jeden Fall
rein wir müssen jetzt mal gucken ach
hier waren wir doch gestern schon ne
weiß ich nicht wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
danke für die Freundlichkeit also ich
weiß auf jeden Fall jetzt dass wir
erstmal nach Bulgarien müssen Leute ich
versuche uns jetzt erstmal zwei Tickets
zu organisieren und ja Kaffee ist gut
und dann melden wir uns ja ja stell mich
mal an das ist der erste Zug den wir
nehmen das glaube ich ja hä der ist ja
voll klein dicker Leute
wir haben auf jeden Fall jetzt gerade 12
Uhr 12 Uhr an dem Freitag ihr könnt ja
gerne mal kommentieren was glaubt ihr
wann kommen wir in Istanbul an also ich
glaube dass wir auf jeden Fall
mindestens boah also ich glaube es wird
eine längere Reise als die letzte um
ehrlich zu sein weil ja das Problem ist
hier spricht halt fast niemand gut
englisch also niemand konnte es richtig
erklären wo wir lang fahren müssen
deswegen schauen wir einfach mal wie es
wird und was dazu kommt ich habe
irgendwie leicht das Gefühl dass ich
krank werde ich war jetzt ein ziemlich
vielen Zügen schon ziemlich viele Leute
gesehen ich fühle mich irgendwie ein
bisschen schlapp aber hoffen wir das
Beste für uns ging es dann auf jeden
Fall erstmal vom Hauptbahnhof in die
bulgarische Grenzstadt genau an der
Grenze zu Rumänien und da war erstmal
das erste Ziel und wir mussten schauen
wir von da aus Weiterkommen das ging
auch wirklich relativ schnell das waren
vielleicht so 50 60 km
viel mit okay Leute kurzer Zwischenstopp
und wurde auf jeden Fall folgende Route
erklärt ich hoffe dass wir das auch
richtig verstanden haben weil wie gesagt
die Leute sprechen irgendwie nicht so
gut Englisch da wir sind jetzt gerade
nach Rust Gefahren heißt das das ist
ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden von Bukarest
weg und müssen hier jetzt gleich
Umsteigen in den Zug danach fährt er da
ist hier Goldstrand also ne kannst ja da
war ich zum Beispiel auch noch nie und
von da aus müssen wir dann schauen dass
wir halt über Burger nach Istanbul
kommen das Problem ist im Internet man
findet nur busconnections dass der Busse
fahren sollen und ich habe keine Ahnung
wie wir das machen werden also ich weiß
es nicht ich habe Videos gesehen wo
Leute schon auch mit zum Nachtzug von
Bukarest nach Istanbul gereistet aber
diesen Zug der heißt ja Bosporus Express
oder hieß so den gibt's nicht mehr also
das haben die uns auch gesagt am Bahnhof
das habe ich auch verstanden das ist
halt mega Kacke und das wusste ich
vorher nicht weil ich habe im Vorhinein
natürlich auch ein bisschen recherchiert
und mir Gedanken gemacht ja das ist halt
der letzte Zug den wir hätten nehmen
müssen diesen Bosporus Express gibt es
halt leider nicht mehr deswegen
versuchen wir es jetzt irgendwie anders
und ich hoffe dass es klappt weil wir
haben jetzt halt Freitag und ist zum
Beispiel muss Montag auch arbeiten und
ja wahrscheinlich
[Gelächter]
den Ruß angekommen mussten wir dann
leider feststellen dass auch das
Streckennetz in Bulgarien wirklich nicht
gut ist und auch wenn man denkt okay in
diese Stadt musste doch safe irgendwie
kommen die ist doch relativ groß ist es
gar nicht mal so einfach auch zeitlich
gesehen man muss sagen wir sind nicht
mit einem Nachtzug Gefahren mussten wir
irgendwie weiterkommen und konnten es
dann nur noch an dem Tag bis nach Warner
schaffen Warner liegt direkt am
Schwarzen Meer und war die einzige
Möglichkeit die für uns Sinn gemacht hat
bis nach Burger hätten wir es gar nicht
mehr geschafft wir haben auch keinen
vernünftigen Zug dahin gefunden und auch
wenn die Strecke gar nicht mal so weit
aussieht ich würde schätzen das waren
vielleicht 300 km waren wir auch an
diesem Tag wieder 8 Stunden unterwegs
echt heftig das hätte ich niemals
gedacht
Leute was geht ich grüße Euch wir haben
jetzt mittlerweile
Freitagabend es ist schon boah fast 10
Uhr würde ich sagen
22:46 Uhr wir sind heute ja gegen Mittag
gestartet ich hätte eigentlich gehofft
dass wir jetzt in einem nicen Nachtzug
sitzen nach Istanbul aber wir sind
gerade in Varna hier ist der Goldstrand
also ich habe den jetzt nicht gesehen
der ist auch nicht so nah hier jetzt
gerade und ich bin noch einfach froh
dass ich jetzt hier sein kann weil man
muss sagen mir geht's echt sehr sehr
schlecht ich fühle mich als hätte ich
Fieber und ich hoffe einfach dass das
nicht schlimmer wird wir haben heute den
ganzen Tag irgendwie versucht und
gedribbelt aber uns haben so viele Leute
heute gesagt dass es gerade keine
Connection gibt und ich weiß dass man
z.B mit Bus fahren könnte aber ja und
ich bin wirklich kurz davor zu sagen
dass wir einfach jetzt morgen also von
war nach Istanbul kann man halt auch
fliegen so weit ist das ja gar nicht
mehr das sind vielleicht 500 km Luft
oder so aber es gibt halt keine
Zugverbindung nichts online nichts an
dürfen wir waren an so vielen Bahnhöfen
es gibt nichts das ist halt so
deprimierend weil ich mir diese Route
eigentlich ausgeguckt habe und das ging
halt safe mal ich möchte jetzt erstmal
schlafen morgen ist ein neuer Tag dann
sieht die Welt schon wieder anders aus
und vielleicht kommen wir es doch
irgendwie hin was man aber mal
festhalten muss wenn in den letzten fünf
Tagen knapp 3000 km mit dem Zug gefahren
und das finde ich schon auf jeden Fall
echt sehr sehr weit und ich habe super
viel erlebt also es hat echt richtig
Spaß gemacht auch wenn es anstrengend
war und nicht gerade am Tiefpunkt der
Reise bin
ich hoffe nicht dass du mit dem Bus
fahren müssen
wir sind jetzt mittlerweile am Flughafen
angekommen und sind dann hoffentlich in
den nächsten zwei Stunden glaube ich
also man fliegt halt wirklich nicht
lange von Warner nach Istanbul mir tut
das natürlich unfassbar Leid und für
mich selber ist es halt auch mega der
Abfahrt weil ich mir wirklich halt als
Ziel gesetzt habe die komplette Strecke
mit dem Zug zu passieren aber es geht
halt nicht also es macht keinen Sinn wir
hätten mit Bus fahren können jetzt die
letzte Strecke das werden glaube ich 8
Stunden gewesen kann ich euch immer
einblenden weil man muss auch dazu sagen
ich bin ja jetzt schon sechs Tage
unterwegs Luis hat sich extra Urlaub
genommen und ja wir müssen einfach jetzt
nach Istanbul kommen weil wir da auch
noch die Stadt sehen wollen und ist halt
ärgerlich ich weiß nicht wann jemand von
euch so eine connection kennt die man
fahren kann schreibt gerne in die
Kommentare für mich ist es halt Kacke
dass ich es nicht 100% durchziehen
konnte also irgendwo kann man nichts
machen ich hoffe das könnt ihr auch
verstehen aber ja so ist das jetzt und
ähm bleibt gern trotzdem noch dran weil
wir machen noch bisschen Istanbul
unsicher ja willst du noch was sagen ich
bin sehr glücklich dass wir mit dem
Flugzeug fliegen mit dem Bus fahren oder
noch mehr mit dem Zug bist du schon bist
du in deinem ganzen Leben schon so viel
Zug gefahren wie in den letzten drei
Tagen oh nein ach so was aber gut ist
mir geht's mittlerweile auf jeden Fall
körperlich wieder besser das ist auf
jeden Fall nice und ich hoffe dass wir
jetzt dann noch heute und morgen ein
bisschen in Istanbul genießen können
weil Montag geht's zurück Luis muss
arbeiten ich muss auch Arbeiten ich
mache nicht nur Youtube Videos was geht
wahrscheinlich
angekommen in Istanbul wir haben jetzt
gerade Samstag der Flughafen hier ist
echt mega modern erste Eindruck ist top
ich war ja noch nie in Istanbul ab jetzt
ins Hotel und dann fahren wir noch zum
Bosporus und so ich freue mich einfach
nur wird bestimmt geil
ich hoffe
[Musik]
die konnektion
so sind jetzt im Hotel kurze roomtour
danach das noch ganz wichtig werde ich
noch mal die ganze Reise zusammenfassen
und euch zeigen was ich komplett bezahlt
habe für die ganzen Züge das haben sich
viele gewünscht und das mache ich
natürlich erstmal muss ich aber sagen
wir sind jetzt in einem ja laut booking
5 Sterne Hotel für einfach nur 60 € die
Nacht und das sieht echt der nice aus
muss ich sagen das ist man hat sogar
hier essen ey jetzt muss man sich mal
vorstellen 60 €, Alter
boah geil ey so Leute was geht
wunderschönen guten Morgen wir waren
gestern Abend noch in Istanbul unterwegs
war echt cool also schon eine riesige
Stadt haben auf jeden Fall super viel
gegessen probiert auf was getrunken und
sind dann so um 2:30 Uhr schlafen
gegangen hier sind ja auch zwei Stunden
vor Deutschland
so Leute wir sind auf jeden Fall gerade
im Taxi und sind gerade über diesen
meisterbrücke Gefahren können und sind
jetzt in Asien geil
wir können jetzt auch hier die Aussicht
glaube ich noch mal viel besser sehen
als gestern da ist einfach also wir sind
ja jetzt auf der europäischen Seite da
seht ihr jetzt dort so die Skyline und
dahinten ist dann die asiatische Seite
da waren wir gestern okay der Plan war
es ja komplett mit Zug zu fahren wir
schon jetzt mitbekommen habt hat nicht
ganz geklappt nur fast also die letzten
ich würde mal schätzen 600 km oder so
ging halt nicht ich zeige euch jetzt
genau was ich bezahlt habe für die
ganzen zu connections und am Ende werde
ich euch auch sagen was das günstigste
gewesen wäre was möglich gewesen wäre
weil ich bin ja auch oft First Class
gefahren habe was teures gebucht und so
und das ist ja dann auch interessant
wäre ja auch witzig wenn das mal wer
nachmacht der erste Zug von London nach
Paris hat mich 317 € gekostet relativ
teuer aber war halt auch eigentlich top
komfortabel Technik die vorherigen
Videos unbedingt aus wenn es noch nicht
gemacht habe dann bin ich weiter
gefahren von Paris nach Zürich für
199 Euro First Class erste Klasse im TGW
ja auch relativ teuer dann ging es
weiter von Zürich Hauptbahnhof nach Wien
Hauptbahnhof mit dem Nachtzug eigentlich
hatte ich 159 bezahlt für ein eigenes
Schlafabteil habe ich nicht bekommen und
dann musste ich 129 Euro für ein
Liegewagen bezahlen da ging es weiter
von Wien Hauptbahnhof bis nach Budapest
mit dem Railjet welcher gleich kommt mit
dem IC das wusste ich nicht tut mir leid
mich war auch selber müde das schon da
habe ich 43 € bezahlt und habe dann
erstmal ein Budapest gepennt wobei ich
euch jetzt die Hotelkosten ähm nicht
verraten werde weil das finde ich jetzt
nicht Teil der Sache ist dann kam Luis
dazu in Budapest und wir sind weiter
Nachtzug gefahren das war die längste
Reise mit über 15 Stunden von Budapest
bis nach Bukarest wir hatten ein eigenes
Schlafabteil ich habe für uns beide
zusammen 210 € bezahlt wenn man es durch
zwei Teil würde ich einfach mal 105 €
hier für mich ergänzen und dann sind wir
glaube ich vorgestern noch von Bukarest
bis nach Varna gefahren da mussten wir
einmal umsteigen und waren dann
irgendwie nach 8 Stunden oder so und
Warner das ging auf jeden Fall auch
preislich klar da habe ich pro Person
ungefähr 37 € bezahlt für diese Wege
genau dann kommen wir jetzt auf den
Endzone so teuer war es Lust dann halt
noch Paprika 100 € 120 Euro für den Flug
genau so teuer war die Reise und ich
blende euch jetzt auch noch mal ein was
das Ganze kosten würde wenn man immer
das günstigste Bucht würde mal schätzen
werden so ungefähr boah 500 € ca auch
schon viel
ich muss trotzdem sagen wir hatten
unfassbar viel Spaß haben viele Städte
gesehen in so kurzer Zeit habe ich noch
nie so viele Städte gesehen das ist ja
auch einfach geil weil man kann sagen
man war überall schon mal und war auf
jeden Fall ein richtig geiles Projekt
Leute ich bedanke mich fürs zuschauen
abonniert super gerne den Kanal für
weitere solcher Videos und mal schauen
wo die Reise das nächste Mal so hingeht
haut rein ciao